hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play followed by Death okay we
went through a water part I don't like
water I now have a pathological fear of
water because of this game yep yes it is
okay ah ha ha oh no oh no oh no oh no
I'm like a pathological fear of
mannequins and water Oh
because of this game hey oh not today
not today not today not today
ah the ladder Oh what out are you
coupons Oh
ah damn it go go go ah I'm gonna look Oh
can't get me I'm too pro where the legs
ah ah ah ah damn you damn you
uh-huh I had a bit of work it didn't
work anyway and then we're in ding dong
damn work ah ah ah down and um oh it
didn't work the frigging ah out here why
didn't it work
it didn't work the ding damn day Oh Oh
work work work work work back back back
ah yeah no I'm almost there I I can make
it I'm the love when I'm loud Adam nice
team I get a lot Adam go on now I'm
right back the dead
oh I'm right back to this Oh make it
make it make it oh I used a war status
for a really long time I began to
realize what kind of mix I'd be from
using I had to press on words in order
find out what had happened in this
castle and its people but most
importantly what was after me oh what is
after me invisible monsters
Oh does it
oh haha what what I owe that was it huh
I guess I I guess I'm not sure what I
was in for I guess that oh you know the
game the game was all the games I've
been playing recently were so long but
hang on just a second I'm not gonna end
this episode here because I'm gonna just
like go right into episode two because I
got absolute two lined up so hold on
just a second I'll be right back in just
a second okay grab back guys
hello everybody welcome back all right
got followed by death chapter 2 line up
right here
okay I really didn't expect the first
one to be that short I mean I was really
surprised because the other custom
stories I mean I guess is chapter 1
chapter 2 but the other custom stories
were like really long and I would have
expected something that highly reviewed
to be a bit longer maybe I just rushed
through it on huh you must escape the
unimaginable horror and find yourself in
the okay same thing must find friends
his arm in the gas hole owner to find
out what's after you okay here we go
boom
hmm now now Abril de Grey curse one of
the most powerful phenomenon in the
world apart to here forever
huh huh
okay.what no rock music earth metal no
good I guess
nut butter nut butter know what ha
uh-huh okay yeah and I went to a chunk o
letter for ya
oh no I got to relive this part ha ha ha
that was gonna transfer me after this I
should run no kidding
bloody awesome abrupt gosh ha ha it
didn't jump at all I want to help that's
not the right way that's not how it was
before
hi epicly oh no no not today
was that just a goop register juice huh
epic box jump got it but I think it
still hit me damn it
yeah Matt eyes okay pish pish paw
whatever all right I'm ready for
unimaginable Horrors um Oh loosened up
and ready to go bring on the pain
the story of followed by death continues
more ladder okay more ladder
Derk Derk Derk
who's that who's that I heard something
something mmm me no likey shovel doodads
I lost all my tinderboxes I wouldn't
expect it to carry things through that's
not a note neither is that
hence I know how to play the game the
guy I'm stupid I didn't box
ah back to the desk has not really been
irritating oh ho maybe a little bit
frustrating to maintain my authority oh
ho but it's becoming more difficult
every move
yeah whatever my servants David William
and Henry still in my bidding dead dead
generaiiy gir to follow my orders mm-hmm
they are not rebelling against me
outright oh but it almost feels like a
seed of mutiny has been planted among
them yeah they hate but it doesn't
matter for a wean to sacrifice anything
and go to any lengths to gain the power
of the great curves
yeah whatever turns evil monster that
I'm a very lucky man to have come across
this book I found some years ago the
Necronomicon Ange to a meeting with a
man who had told me about some very
interesting things books and tomes
concerning topics that people dare on
the whisper about yeah okay things that
frighten many but could be very useful
for very ancient man like myself mm-hmm
such a man would find those books very
valuable indeed very valuable so I don't
mean to poke fun at them actually yes I
do that's all like I poke fun things to
make up for my own scared miss all right
um up dark okay don't be in the dark
hide all pages fluttering in the wind
Oh not even scary
oh shut up guy anything behind the
painting go
I don't think I've ever heard that noise
before are you miss having to moan about
oh how do you like me now huh huh huh
give me that
where's a light no light fine Gobbo
enjoy oh it's dark in here
okay the books arrived his boots praised
oh I actually opened the container but I
was quickly disappointed by the contents
yeah sure you were it sold its horn and
they were playing bland and useless it
felt like almost everything in the chest
were just a couple of dollar painting of
thorn and peasants horror stories of
porn the seven no purpose except poor
Anne through a couple of years I
reconsidered and decided to take a look
once more at its content this is porn we
won there was one book that's caught in
my eye as soon as says doctor dammit
what the hell oh sorry I accidentally
clicked I'll go back I'll go back there
it is here we go ah ah read there was
one book that caught my eye as soon as I
saw it the name of this mr. Kahn was
simply the rebirth written by untrained
Daniels a wise man who is considered one
of the greatest wizard retain his words
if we still more likely the key to his
power lie in this book okay happy good
good
everything's settled now moving on ha 10
what what what do you write always have
collapsed I need to go around Wow that
yeah I could have observed that myself
good thing they build blazer
that's weird wind being down here very
strange I shouldn't have looked at torch
so moving right along anyway it done now
all right whatever it's a lot I don't
want to look oh no not more darkness not
more goopy goop Oh tinderbox can't
escape from me okay get back I'm so
tough turn the box no I know obsessed
the book of the rebirth you know with it
I will soon possess its power power the
brew tells about the great curse a
ritual of the Damned which plants people
immortality sure cost of turning them
into mindless beasts earth according to
the book the great curse can be cheated
in such a way that you gain the powers
unlikely without any negative
side-effects I've been studying this
book for a long time now and I am
certain that what the book says can be
done I doubt that very sure texts to
David who has confirmed them to be
accurate now the four of us venture into
the dungeons of my castle and perform
the great curse in an alternative way
right it probably involves murder
anything under the stairs what's in here
another book nope
yeah I gotta do something here yeah wait
wait wait for it uh-huh yeah oh damn it
never mind then I'll get this one
ah yeah Oh such a badass okay where we
going oh I'm not doing so well ever I'm
okay I need to oil though huh huh
No
no no good okay yeah one bunch so lose
the collapsed hallway all right nothin
there
huh dark sound cool but shut up guy
don't be groaning ah is this really
necessary
something in this feels really fishy to
me of course it is necessary otherwise
we wouldn't be here
she shouldn't be so paranoid all the
time we'll in you've said that there's
still a long way to go
how big is this cotton anyway I don't
know my ancestors built this cat's a
long time ago its deepest dungeons have
not been seen by a living soul for some
time though well I have to say this
castle is really impressive considering
that it was built so long ago yes I also
find this castle very impressive indeed
don't you think so too Henry yes good we
need to use the old elevator to reach
the lowest levels of this castle mm-hmm
this way this way okay so I'm gonna
assume that all those guys are dead all
dead hello lion hear me roar Lannister
words okay hi let me up the stairs are
you like Simon can't even walk up a
flight of stairs why am I going slow all
of a sudden I'm not going really
ridiculously slow now
the book that Francis held had some
interesting carvings on the front
Francis had written it written had it
well hidden okay I need to find the book
I'm guessing I got a note what I read I
should check the living rooms for any
useful equipment I may find and monsters
it's so light in here I know it's all
the lights are gonna go out but anyway I
gotta end this episode here thank you
guys so much for watching and as always
I will see you in the next part bye-bye